good afternoon members
uh agenda item one uh Chairman's notices
um this is the uh usual uh uh good
afternoon and welcome to this meeting of
the council
um on the 30th of March
2023 my name is councilor Boyce and I am
the chairman of the council
members we are streaming this meeting
live as well as recording and by being
present in the meeting you are giving
your consent to being recorded during
each item please put your hand up to
indicate if you wish to speak I will
then invite you at the appropriate time
please note that your YouTube live
stream sound recording is dependent on
the correct use of the microphone
microphones therefore can I ask that
when invited to speak you remember to
turn on your microphone and turn it off
when finished please reference the page
or paragraph number when referring to
the gender papers and keep your
contribution as clear and concise as
possible
um a general item two Miss bird
apologies for absence
[Music]
the member for two councilor councilor
Channel
thank you I think councilor Morgan was
read out his present chairman all right
um and also can I just say
um I I can't recall it being a council
of keys
um was it called out he may be coming
later councilor Orly I think
um not and councilor hubner has given
his and he won't be here I believe for
both for both for the whole meeting
chairman thank you thank you
um members
um it's my intention uh to
um take this business of this meeting in
two parts as you have been advised uh
from uh from now till five we'll attempt
to get all the public business
um done Council of flu because now
you're shaking your head that's what I'm
doing
uh and we will we will adjourn the
meeting uh either when we've finished
um the items up to the PNC items uh or
before
uh and
um because it's a four-hour stint
I intend to have a comfort Break about
in a couple of hours three-ish
um I I hope that's
thank you and clearly I wasn't listening
because I don't understand what you mean
um chairman are you saying that we're
going to deal with all of the public
Parts including emotions
around five o'clock yeah hopefully
before five but if we don't finish by
five then that will of course roll over
to the evening meeting but I can't take
the PNC items because the officers won't
be present this afternoon they won't be
present till this evening
is that clear chairman it's clear but
clearly the process is is is not because
if the officers aren't on standby to
hear PNC and and for example Jen say
this part of the meeting finished at
three o'clock well then we adjourn till
seven
well Kevin it would have been nice to
have that been certainly imparted to me
Jim and I'm I'm sorry but I I find that
very difficult to grasp and I apologize
for standing right for you to stay
right uh
we've done apologies for absence uh
gender item three minutes to confirm the
meetings of the council meeting held uh
on the 22nd of February Pages 7 to 26
and the continuation meeting on the 23rd
of February contained on pages 27 to 36.
councilor leader
thank you chairman I'm sorry I can't
find my bit of paper and I'm sure miss
bird will assist me
um I believe there's some correction uh
on accuracy chairman if I may present
those
um it makes reference to me um declaring
an interest to do with the business
rates and um I did not uh do it at that
point I think what's what's added to
confusion was I actually and I've spoken
to miss Byrd so she is aware I declared
under an item there were the SNR um
obstruction resources committee minutes
and I declared under item 7B
um a gender item 12 which was to do with
council tax and that's to do with second
council tax regarding empty properties
and second homes I declare then I think
what happened you altered the agenda
items on the meeting and it is reflected
um no hence why I declared it then and
then it shows later on the minutes and
it is recorded correctly that my
Declaration was indeed in respect of
that it's also then going on to the
minutes to do with the main budget
debate chairman I haven't got the page
before me but it's um to do with Mr
Leslie's introduction regarding the
budget and there were four bullet points
and I'm afraid on one of them chairman
it identifies that the council tax is
sick pounds whatever it was 35 per week
and of course that was annually and in
fact the council tax value is 12 people
per week to a Bandy property so I wanted
to just correct that and also then when
I sum up chairman under the leader it
does say um it makes reference to things
and now at Cost of Living and the
services and even though the savings
were made but it retained the services
that were important to members I think
that word should be residence chairman
so I do apologize not having the detail
of pages but miss bird is aware yes I'm
I'm aware Miss bird has sent me the
corrections which uh I can now can I ask
Council that to agree these changes
yes thank you chairman
um I I like to follow things and I like
to write amendments and changes down and
I've not understood a word what cancer
the leaders actually just said you cut
when when you actually discussing or
disagreeing or what's whatever you want
to do with minutes you're supposed to
reference the page number the minute
number
Etc chairman so I'm sorry I will not be
agreeing it because I don't know what
the leader was talking about thank you
can you can you help please
your amendments your suggested
amendments
um
there's a real reference to the agenda
writer under which council Mrs child
declared her interest it should be a
gender item 7B which is the strategy and
resources Committee of the 26th of
January a gender item 12 which is the
council tax discretionary discount
levels uh the actual interest that is
declared is correct it's just a
reference to the wrong item under that
and the second one is in relation to
page nine item eight which is the
2023-24 budget medium term Financial
strategy paragraph four the fourth
bullet point contains an error and
should actually refer to six pounds 35 a
year for boundary property increase then
and not a week as well as per minute and
the third also is under a January 28
it's on page 11 and it's paragraph to
the last sentence should refer to
Residents rather than member's where the
three changes and I'm quite happy to
give you help them for those two and
cancer staff
no chairman have made them thank you
thank you thank you chairman councilor
fluka
thank you just to help things I'll give
way to them oh thank you can I just
thank Spurs for that um chairman because
I'm now in my mod.gov so I'm grateful to
her I had spoken to her before and
actually coming up with the page numbers
but I think the essence of what my
statement was
um is as Miss Birds read out and she's
now applied the details of the exact
pages and exactly what item thank you
did you want to say something Council
Fluker yes sir thank you chairman
um chairman page 10 I'm not quite sure
it's sort of halfway down Jim and it's
the paragraph that starts
um Council fluke the the ward member for
southminster uh and then at the end of
that paragraph it says this proposal was
duly seconded well my understanding was
determine that
um that that was agreed by a cent that
we would have this working group so I
want to be I feel as though those words
are missing because at the moment they
were supposed to put forward which was
right and proper and in the best
interests of this Council which was
Julie seconded and this
agreed by a senate of council but the
minutes don't reflect that so perhaps
you can put me in your comfort zone
um I don't know if Mr Bird's here no no
she's there
um but yeah
uh who can help me here
was was there a resolution
um Miss bird
um sorry
I think that was uh
that was The Proposal that a full budget
would be carried out my cross chamber
cross-county working group and I thought
back to council with recommendations
this spring
that is that the paragraph I believe how
Supreme is referring to music Council
Fluker
certainly certainly chairman and I made
that proposal it was due to seconded and
I believe yes chairman chairman I can't
direct the clerk any further no no
paragraph counseling councilor fluke and
the wars member for South Minster this
is what you're talking about who
absolutely
uh what does the uh minutes say
s
that without checking my notes and
checking the tape I couldn't really
advise further than I was made in German
I'm sorry okay uh Mr Dodson have you got
a view on this
again not not from memory chairman I'd
have to to look at the details
um I will councilor fluka we can't
um
uh agree this this particular minute uh
at the moment uh it will need as Miss
bird has said for her to further check
and all I can say is that we'll need to
go to the next meeting unless unless you
can agree uh uh with officers and the
clerk
um a suitable amendment in the meantime
between now and the statutory annual
level
my view we don't accept that minute well
no chairman we do accept that minute
because it's absolutely critical
chairman to the well-being of the
financial position in this Council which
is what this is all about and and my the
reason why I bought this out now was
because we know that we probably won't
get back to business as usual this
Council uh until after the strata
Channel which means it's another three
months down the line by which time we
will be well into the budgetary period
my understanding of when I made this
proposal which I believe was duly
seconded by councilor Stan that buyer
sent it was agreed to from and Kevin I
you can imagine why the members agree
because it is so important that from day
one we get into the budget I can't I
can't confirm or deny what you're saying
if it was by a cent then the tape will
show that and Miss Byrd will be able to
pick it up from there if the tape does
not show that it was by ascent
then it just stands as you made the
proposal uh it should it should actually
have have said it was agreed or not
agreed and and I can't help you any more
than that councilor Stan thank you
chairman can can we actually just defer
this set of minutes till tonight no uh
why not it's literally so I'm sure the
clerk is excellent and can check
dashboard is that is that um uh doable
yeah
okay thank you uh uh good suggestion
councilor Stan thank you
can we uh
is that sounded patronizing
it was meant as a compliment
councilor Stevens
thank you chair on a completely
different and less generic matter I
can't access any of my notes would
somebody from it through you chair be
able to come and help me and sort my
computer out when like now I can't
access any of my notes for today's
meeting now if if anyone's available to
help me it would be appreciated we can't
we can't adjourn the meeting uh to do
that uh Miss Stevens
uh
um Mr Holmes is there anybody available
on it at present chairman I'll do a
check on teams and I'll try and resolve
it for you as soon as I can
go yeah yeah
um
right so we we agree the minutes except
for that particular one at the moment
right thank you
uh a generating four Declaration of
interests
uh to disclose the existence and nature
of any disclosable pecuniary interests
other registerable interests and
non-registerable interests relating to
items of business on the agenda have in
regard to paragraph nine and appendix
B of the code of conduct for members the
members are also reminded they are also
required to disclose any such interest
as soon as they become aware should the
need arrive throughout the meeting
any Declarations of Interest
no thank you
um
agenda item five public questions to
receive questions from the members of
the public by which prior notification
in writing has been received
uh Miss bird has only been received
right thank you
agenda item six Chairman's announcements
um now first of all
um under Chairman's announcements
there's a statement from Mr a short
statement from Mr Dodson which is a
statement and is not open to the debate
Mr Dodson
thank you chairman
um statement refers to the five-year
housing land Supply
and I can confirm as of today the 30th
of March 2023 using the council's
present methodology for calculating the
five-year housing land Supply the figure
stands at 5.1 years
to be caveated
with the fact that the work to close the
year
2022-23 with regard to the monitoring of
the housing figures has not yet been
completed and therefore does not replace
the annual housing Supply position that
requires officers to undertake some
verification site visits complete the
check of all council tax and building
control records for commencements
completions and expiries therefore
this figure may change and could move it
move either up or down once the end of
year checks have been completed for the
annual five-year housing land Supply
report which will be presented for
approval to council at a later date for
now the work of the five-year housing
land Supply working group continues and
it's therefore important to recognize
that any change to the methodology it
recommends to council could also affect
the land Supply position thank you
thank you Mr Dodson
um members
um
I was elected to this Council in May
1983 which next May will be
40 40 years
um in that time there's been many highs
and lows I won't refer to uh to the lows
but you're all aware of the importance
of the voluntary sector
and we I consider that this Council has
been a partner of the voluntary sector
over that time and have achieved many
great things and members you are all
part of the voluntary sector
um
it's a a council that 28 or more years
ago became debt free because of the
stock transfer we've been debt free
um ever since
um using the original
money that came forward
and the right to buy a clawback that we
had that brought in many more Millions
one of the highs was the 2.3 million
pounds we got from Mr Prescott
I don't remember when in which we
rebuilt the seawall just past the hive
key along
um
a little way along the
um from Park
uh reconstituted the
Valley put in the splash park and and
The Galleon
which have proved to be a great
attraction
in this time
um I can't claim any achievements
for myself
but as a member of this Authority we
have many many
achievements Moreland has always punched
above its its weight
my failure has been the same perhaps as
many other others not being able to stop
inappropriate over development as as we
see it
members you're part of the voluntary
sector
you'll be some of you will be standing
down some of you the lecturer will stand
down I I I I I I wish all of you whether
you're standing
again whether you get reelected
um the best of luck
[Applause]
uh agenda item seven minute book there
are no recommendations coming forward
from committees
the gender item eight
minutes of meetings of the council
there's three there
uh any questions on any of those
no thank you
oh there's four more underneath uh
agenda item nine notice emotions
um
before I call Council of uh Fluker uh I
have decided to disallow
um also uh motion six
uh pick under the six month rule
um this is this motion six is asking to
increase the number of um
committee meetings
the council only last month
or the last meeting approved
uh the the calendar so I'm just allowing
uh that
um I don't know whether you will want to
proceed with
uh motion uh the first motion Council
yes please chairman and I'll speak to
you well
um
the legal reasons
very much what I hear those to say the
SRA uh well would you then need the
motion that's what I was going to say
well chairman I think I I I I have not
and this is this is the most shocking
thing about this and not least of all
you're going to reconvene this meeting
at seven o'clock I just looked on the
website it's certainly not what the
residents of South Minister understood
last night they thought we were starting
at one and can I just say hello because
I know they're listening in
um but according to the website and
according to the the summons chairman of
this meeting there is no mention of it
being adjourned so the public think that
this meeting is starting at one and
finishes when the business is concluded
not when you're ruling and saying that
we're going to have a break which
potentially chairman could be for us
well it was well advertised in front
Council of fluka
um
the issue is are you going to move
motion one or are you going to allow
yeah thank you to give the legal
I'd like to hear the legal and then I'll
move motion one I think well I don't I I
I shall just ask you then to Move Motion
One
no I I think
I'm the Champion
are you going to move motion one or not
um
yeah I'll give weight because I'm I'm
currently someone's listening to this
meeting and giving me legal advice so
I'll give way so that I can read that
properly thank you chairman can I just
actually ask that you
you have actually stopped which is well
you're right which is exactly what
you've just said you've said that you
would provide the legal information of
why you did and I think we got an email
some of us got an email referring to
that so I would only think it's it's
fair and you don't have to be fair even
though it's nearly your last meeting
chairman but it would be really nice for
the residents and members that you do
explain it because you have you you
that's chairman you've yielded that
stick saying that you would tell us why
now because it's really not fair
chairman all I'm saying is
reason for motion one which is asking me
to give the reasons if I've given the
reasons
I I mean
yeah well but that wouldn't stop me
giving the reasons
would you like to read out the legal
reason please
I'm not playing not yet
just down to there okay
thank you chair
would you like me to stand please please
yes
part four of the Constitution and
specifically sections 5.11 and section
7.1 make it clear that members cannot
take part in the recruitment or
management of offices below director
level these individuals are employed by
the council and are accountable to the
head of paid service the working
Arrangements of staff are an operational
matter and dealt with via delegation to
the head of paid services and through
managers who determine the operational
needs of the service and ensure Staffing
Arrangements meet operational need if
the Motions were to be passed the matter
would leave the council open to claims
against it under both employment and
equality legislation under the equality
act the council must consider reasonable
adjustments to be applied in response to
the needs of an employee with a
disability having a blanket requirement
for clerks to attend evening meetings
would be in breach of the equality act
as it would not allow managers to
consider and Implement reasonable
adjusted for its staff a failure to
adapt to the needs of staff could also
result in a claim for constructive
dismissal
thank you Miss Holmes
I can't see um any reason why that that
advice could not have been imparted to
members in advance of that meeting I
agree partly with it but not all of it
chairman I believe that the the council
can ask any officer to consider anything
in this Council whether it's operational
or not it was asking the header paid
service that members weren't saying this
is what you've heard the reasons why I
have said that it won't be heard right
okay there's no argument
would you allow me to make a short
statement in relation to the rest of the
motions
to the rest of the motions
it's it's your your emotions
Gemini I think first of all can I wish
you all the best with your retirement
and uh oh I am tempted to stand in sales
but I understand I understand that is a
very busy gig from what I can hear but
um just between the two of us I
understand that potentially no one's
standing in tillingham and I wouldn't
put it past you but I think after all
these years if anybody deserves a good
happy retirement uh and then then it's
you and I'm delighted chairman that
you've decided to spend the rest of your
retirement I'll put it in my Parish
where I live thank you
um Kevin the one you don't represent
um
I'm sorry to change the tone completely
of this meeting but Tim and I've
recently been threatened and bullied and
intimidated by this Council I never
thought I'd have to stand here and say
that after 12 years
um we can agree that previously you
accepted motions three and seven and I
think six now and they were due to be
considered that the follow-on meeting on
the 22nd of February but because of my
own business commitments that day
chairman and the short notice I had to
withdraw a number through the motions
um I've noted chairman from the report
that you chose to redact motions three
and seven on the report contained on
page 38 and 39.
um
I find that quite unusual not least of
all because those motions actually
appear unredacted verbatim on the
council agenda on the 22nd of February
and over since these minutes since these
this agenda has been published I've had
no end of inquiries about this why
they've been redacted why were they just
not left there and said the chairman is
well they're not going to be considered
that said I see no reason why you had to
redact them on the basis that you were
not going to accept them
um in my mind chairman the redaction of
my emotions today adds to my sense of
being threatened bullied and
intimidating nobody nobody has come to
me before this meeting and asked me
where we're going with all of this I
would have thought if nothing else it
would have been polite chairman that
someone would have contacted me about
the league of advice so that that could
have been discussed why leave it to the
last minute you know we're not here to
showboat we're here to do the business
of council and that may be rich coming
for me
um chairman in um in a nutshell chairman
um I've lost all confidence in this
administration of this Council
and therefore withdraw all of my motions
one two three four five six seven and
eight in order that they may be
considered by the new Administration
following the elections in May and and I
can see a few heads have gone down
chairman because I've just done that in
accordance with the rules and everybody
now has an email including Community
Services Mr Dodson and uh Miss Hughes uh
saying that they are withdrawal now is
that is that with the agreement of your
second there certainly Tim and it's not
end with agreement it's with hope
chairman that at least two of us and
we'll bring them forward in May can we
um that's it uh
I'll just give a few words of
explanation your your
numerous motions that have disrupted
this Council the last couple of meetings
I allowed originally to go forward onto
the agenda
um paper because of motion one
which says
which bullies the chairman
into
um
explaining why now the chairman this
chairman and all previous chairmans that
I've ever known
of always
explained why emotions are not been
um
heard by a council
and the reasons given I allowed all your
emotions to go forward because of motion
one
and the residents of southminster would
if if I hadn't if I'd disallowed those
motions at that time wouldn't know what
motion one was talking about
because they wouldn't appear on the
agenda paper yeah
and that is why they were all put
forward in the first instance
that's my story and I'm sticking to him
oh I'm not expecting you to respond I'm
just telling you if there's any bullying
it's the other way around because motion
one point for the chairman Point support
chairman yeah uh which point of order
which role which role and uh uh want to
roll the procedures chairman engaging
with members it's in there someone um
chairman based on what the chairman just
said I report myself to the monitoring
officer on the basis that the chairman
has just called me out as a bully now
yes you did end up I'm reported to the
Ayah oh well that's that's that's fair
enough uh but the main thing is that you
withdrawn all your emotions
and you've wasted this council's time
you've caused this extra
afternoon's meeting which is now if we
finish early it's going to be a long gap
between now and seven o'clock thank you
councilor Fluker well thank you
council's Boyce because if you'd asked
me about this we would not be in this
position you have a summons that says a
meeting starts at one o'clock today if
you decide to adjourn for five hours I
think that's at the expense of the
public thank you
um agenda item 10 questions in
accordance with procedure rule six three
which notices mean given I don't believe
there has been any
agenda item 11 appointment of debt to
the Electoral registration officer
um Mr Dodson
sorry penny
leader
I will be giving it to him
but chairman uh this is for Council to
avoid the deputy electoral registration
officer to carry out duties in the uh in
the event that the ero is not available
and uh the Electoral registration
officer cannot appoint the deputy
themselves and hence why this uh paper
has come before Council today there's
nothing onerous in it chairman it's just
very good housekeeping but I will let Mr
Dodson come in now so thank you very
much German
thank you yes it's the the leader
indicates this is a hopefully a
straightforward report
um that the lead elections and
Democratic services manager be appointed
as the deputy elections registration
electoral registration officer
um as the report says and as the leader
indicated that as returning officer I'm
able to delegate responsibilities but as
in the role of electoral registration
officer it that's not in my gift hence I
have to ask to counsel and under the um
the the election Act
uh the implementation of the election
act 2022 specifically the introduction
of voter ID the Electoral registration
officer is now required to sign
temporary voter Authority certificates
that can be provided for the five days
including the day of the election prior
to election day and that's more
specifically the reason for asking for
for this delegation to to enable that to
operate operationally
thank you chairman thank you members
agree Council Fluker chairman I'll just
take this opportunity to remind the
returning officers promise to inspect
the suitability of the polling station
at southminster in particular the
disabled access I looked at it last
night chairman it's not in good shape
that's that's uh finding a hook to hang
a question on uh thank you very much
talking about this just before the
meeting you're the first person in the
last four years to do so thank you very
much chairman um chairman there's a
point of interest because obviously I'm
very very interested in the the the the
financial success of this Council and
everything that goes with it
um in the past returning officers we
know that they can choose to receive a
fee from the government and can Council
confirm whether such a fee is being
taken and whether the council will be
compensated for the loss of time
appointed to the post from which the
returning officer is appointed this was
something which the chief executive did
uh chairman and I'd I'd be interested
was happy but actually is a very very
tenuous hook uh Mr Dodson thank you in
vented the the fee for a returning
officer this is a legal requirement it's
not not for the the returning it's not a
choice of the returning officer under
under the law then the the returning
officer and all staff who are working on
elections should be paid for that work
separate to their duties
um for the council
to create a clear line of separation
between the council and the duties in
relation to the election so it's not at
the discretion of any of those offices
or the returning officer it's part of
the election Act
thank you
um agenda item 12 update of the customer
strategy in one Morton District
Community Hub Pages 43-48 leader
uh thank you chairman
um this is exactly what it is it's an
update for members but they're both um
our points that members are very
interested in and especially I think the
community Hub and particularly obviously
the commercial strategy
um I refer to it in my Leader's speech
it's uh currently uh the reviews being
undertaken and the key principles of the
strategy which were endorsed in July 22
chairman formed the basis of this it
recognizes this actually I'm very
pleased to report and I know members
that will be as well to support
residents who are unable to use the
digital service that's a very important
part are online and and sure we have
telephone and face to face to avoid
exclusion the seven principles of uh
which underpin this are contained within
the report chairman their key principles
and also there's key milestones and a
timetable it the refreshed customer
strategy will reflect new corporate plan
and priorities and newly published data
and relevant policies
um chairman if I could Pat sound over
and the community hub update is
regarding something that's come out of
the uh one Malden District
um whereby it was agreed that we should
look into a community Hub there's
working groups being established and
looking at how we actually support the
current Community hubs then looking to
have a look to a midi Hub regarding
Northern District Council where its
offices may be based but if I can hand
over I think it's to Mr Holmes on this
one Jim I'll be grateful thank you very
much
chairman actually it's my customers
managers I'll hand over to Mrs Green
oh Mr screen
oh you're here all right thank you
members at the bat and we'll stop with
me
um so the the update on the community
helpers
um as the leader has stated it came out
originally of the
um one Malden District
um partnership and it is something that
we did have in existence prior to covid
um and it's something that we very much
wanted to build on so we do have a
working group that includes members of
voluntary sector and the intention is is
that we don't want to create a brand new
Hub the first thing we want to do is
actually to work with the hubs that are
already out there because one of the
things that our voluntary Partners have
said loud and clear is they don't want
to for us to create something that will
kind of replace what they're doing what
they want us to do is to add value to
what's already there we also need to
identify if there are any gaps in the
current provision so the the current
intentions are is that we will roll this
out as what we've termed a virtual Hub
so this is where where the partners will
formally come together to ensure that we
are working alongside each other and
that we can ensure that there is that
transfer of information and that
customers can be directed to the right
organization and the approach we use is
a kind of no wrongdoor approach so
regardless of whichever partner that
customer goes to that they are unable to
refer that person pass them on pass
their information on to the right
partner organization
that will be done through the
um through our Handover and that will
give us some data that will help us
understand what sort of services the
customers have identified that they need
is their existing provision and what
else that those customers might need so
that will help form sort of stage two
which is when we then to start to look
at actually what do we need to provide
so the very first stage which we're
actually looking to get up and running
very quickly is that virtual Hub so
there will be
um a branding that we would all be able
to use there will be sort of joint
training and a jointly agreed way of
being able to share information across
the organizations so we will then build
upon that to then identify what is
needed and at the end of this process we
can identify exactly what is required
whether it's an additional Hub in the
council offices whether it's our staff
working closer alongside some of our
partners or something different so what
we didn't want to do is to preempt what
we thought might be required so this
staged approach will enable us to
improve the partnership working that we
already have build up on that and then
identify what the requirements are to
provide what our customers need
thank you members very happy to take any
questions
councilor Fleming
thank you chair
um my screen I was at the one Malden
District meeting here in the council
offices on the 19th of December and at
other meetings my understanding was that
it would be a physical Hub in the
council offices that's what I took away
at the end of that meeting so I'm a
little surprised to hear that it will
just be a virtual Hub so I'm interested
to learn what has occurred since that
meeting on the 19th of December and now
thank you
thank you Council feminine so no one is
saying that we're not going to provide a
hardback the council offices what we're
going to do is to take it as a stage by
stage and identify what the requirements
are and what Partners potentially need
to be at the council offices or at those
hubs so that's so this is very much a
staged approach what we don't want to do
is to jump straight from where we are
straight into the delivery of a hub and
what we wanted to do is to have a staged
approach so that we can ensure that we
have got our partners on board we
understand what those requirements are
and that we've got part of the we
understand what the partner commitment
is
um Council Fleming you want to come back
thank you chair
um thank you Miss green with all due
respect but that was the 19th of
December and we're now at the end of
March um I could probably take me an
hour to write all of that down for you
what was needed who who could be here so
I just I'm a puzzled by the delay to be
quite honest with you thank you
you need to respond
um
uh thank you thank you chairman so there
have been various meetings with our
partners and we have identified a couple
of key Partners
um to work with which includes a CVS so
they have been part of the working group
so part of that has been engaging more
widely with the voluntary community and
several meetings with the working group
uh thank you chairman I I'm as baffled
as councilor for I mean on this uh way
back last year when we were talking
about this community Hub it was about
all the different Partnerships not just
the CVS that were coming to do this it
was about the NHS it was about having
lots of different representations across
the board
Ms Green says that there is already some
Community hubs
could you tell me where those Community
hubs exist currently in the district
where they physically are at the moment
because I don't know any and the whole
point of this was to bring a physical
partnership with us and other bodies
together so that people can have a
drop-in center and access a range of
services all at the same time we're now
diluting this have you got a list Miss
Green
um I don't have one available
um chairman we are in the process of
pulling that information together and
I'm very happy to do an out an update
for members outside of this meeting
um councilor Miss green hasn't got the
list available but she will supply them
later did you want to come back on
anything else
so it was going clearly stated
what she just said that there are
currently Community hubs existing
are there or aren't there yes or no it's
in the report there must be
members there are various hubs um across
the community and perhaps not in the way
that
um
they would be classed as a full
community Hub so they will be the be
hubs that are led by the voluntary
organizations
how long the screen would it take you to
compile uh the list for councilor siddle
and members
one of my colleagues is already working
on this chairman so I'll need to provide
that shouldn't take too long can you
give any idea of any Hub at the moment
to tell us
members my my colleague Mr Fulcher is
currently working on this as I said I'm
very happy to provide a full update
after the meeting for you
councilor stamp
s yeah thank you chairman
um
similar Essence I mean when this one
modern group was was formed and
everything it was supposed to be the
greatest thing since sliced bread I
thought oh we were led to believe and I
don't think many things have actually
come from it every update we get is it's
like progressing this is happening
that's happening and I've not seen
anything tangent or that we could
actually put a hook on
um or whatever the saying is today
chairman
um I am a little bit concerned in the
facts of and I will go on about this and
the councilor Mays was meeting with me
the other day and it was she's she's a
great green advocate for lack of paper
well and and she made it quite clear
that she was unhappy with me because I
use paper
chairman I find it discriminatory that I
am not provided with paper and I feel
that some of this report because it
actually says here invite and impact on
the environment reducing Out Printing
reducing that need for customers to
travel to council offices Etc and I put
big letters discrimination yeah I need
to see in paper I cannot use computer
screens like the rest of you do for 12
hours a day without me having
substantial headaches problems eye drops
Etc so I think we are being
discriminative and I also think by
having virtual hubs we are going back on
the motion that we think we're at the
last council meeting when we're doing an
open door if you're going to do virtual
how can people walk in to on a virtual
thing it's not virtual is it German it
is virtual it's not encouraging customer
service and I see this as a backwards
step and I'd like it noting that I do
find it discriminatory that I do not get
provided with paper copies and it cost
me 65 pound a month to actually print my
own stuff off thank you
um
counselor White
um thank you Mr chairman and um I'm
afraid I'm I'm in a vein of everybody
else I mean since lockdown I understand
that we lost a lot of the contact center
but I I think one more than District's
been brilliant we have put forward a lot
of strategies we have been working well
with the voluntary services but I'm also
certain that we agreed to have a member
of Staff available in the front office
at all times and their role was to
contact the relative departments should
there be a problem so they could get
something resolved in the offices and on
3.14 and 3.15 which is the risks fresh
stress she recognizes the need to have a
strong Focus providing additional
support for our customers that are
unable to use Digital Services
um it then goes on to say to promote
digital inclusion and then 3.15 starts
evidence shows us that excess additional
Services provides a wealth of
opportunities well yes if you're digital
Savvy but we have an aging population
and we have people that need support and
I mean I I found out I found our
telephone contact center very good and I
actually put forward that we extended
the hours of the um telephone operating
system I don't know what happened with
that and we can't leave this Hub just to
the voluntary Services we can't just
leave it to the CVS or whoever's going
to pick it up and I think this is
something I would like to see coming
forward because it is vitally important
and it is something I've been asking for
for the last four years so you know what
happened to the officer we were going to
have in the um Council offices to assist
members of the public
thank you Mr chairman I just really want
to pick up the point that uh councilor
stamp uh raised so I was under the
impression that the last council meeting
we passed a motion to say that should be
an open door policy from nine to five
and I can't see this particular policy
it's actually is in in play with that
and I would suggest that that this is in
fact lies in the face of that particular
aspiration that was put forward by
members back then thank you councilman
thank you Council Morgan
thank you chair um
there's I agree with everything that's
been said I don't want to go over old
ground and yeah well it is but I just
want to share a small experience of why
um we had to motion so many motions in
the past to get um avoid members voices
listened to
um I put in my electoral papers yes I am
standing I'm not disappointed to some
um and I came up and the Electoral
officer is it Claire Mr Holmes at Claire
Hawk yeah yeah absolutely fantastic
officer I'll put that on record couldn't
be more helpful exactly what an officer
is and um while I was in there and
handed it to to Claire
um she accepted as I walked out this
very elderly lady and gentleman walked
in and they went up to their front desk
and the lad on the desk
um it's a good good afternoon yeah how
can I help you the lovely lady said I
want to pay my council tax please
and he's first he said have you used the
telephone system No Love Low love I
can't use that this is nearly verbaton I
wish I'd have recorded it and uh he said
have you used the online portal and she
would no love we we can't use that and
the bloke said we don't know how to use
that love and to his credit the Young
led behind a desk actually went across
and said well look I can help you but
you'll have to you know go beyond this
screen and do it and I just wondered
what that would have been like if we
didn't have that presence there so this
really reinforces why we need to have
bums on seats faces facing people and I
know it's a collaborative approach but I
think that's the approach to go because
that's what we're missing
that's what we're missing on there and I
think it's absolutely critical if you
look at the resident survey performance
we're not we're not performing
incredibly well at all from the feedback
from What the residents actually say so
I think it's an opportunity that we can
take to increase that Saturday with
residents not customers remember the
distinction the customers have a choice
residents don't so that's just an
observation to share with members and
officers thank you councilor Hull
thank you thank you for listening
um I just also like to say why it's so
important on Friday a young 35 year old
lady was found in
oh sorry
um in Malden and she died four days
previously and her neighbors had to find
her after reporting her several times to
Peabody's
um she had no had no bed she was found
in a cardboard box and she just needed
some help so perhaps if something like
this had been open a half she might know
to come to it
as
I think Miss green wants to come back
with some information or some further
points before I came to council
dispensely
chairman just to reassure members that
our reception service which is manned by
our customer services staff is open five
days a week as members requested from
nine till four every day there's been
that that was implemented the day
following council's decision so first of
all I wanted to reassure you with that
secondly is absolutely Our intention to
implement further improvements and to
deliver what is required by the
community in terms of a community Hub
um as I said this this intention is to
do on a stage basis so the first is put
the first things in place which is to
get the um the building blocks in place
with our partners
identify what partners are needed as
part of the community Hub and then the
third stage will be the delivery of the
physical Hub
um so we have done quite a lot of work
with our voluntary partners and there is
ex and concern expressed that if the
council set up a hub initially that it
might draw people away from the existing
support that is there so this has been
done alongside those existing hubs and
to ensure that we support what's already
there but to make sure that this will
fill the Gap so I just want to reassure
members this is not in any way shape or
form not to deliver the Hub but it's to
do it in a staged approach so what we're
able to deliver is what is actually
required and we do have those Partners
on board
um that we're going to meet the needs of
our most vulnerable customers
catch this thing uh councilor spenceley
thank you chair well first of all all
I'm going to say is
um
having everything virtually is not a
full solution to socialize isolation and
I hope that we can be reassured by what
Mrs Green has just said because I would
hate to see this be a gradual excuse to
not have the physical Hub and I really
do take Assurance from what Mrs Green
has just said that of course that won't
happen
and I'd like to move on to the report to
the customer strategy itself on page 46
at paragraph six
um and we talk here about learning from
customer customer feedback and I hope
that applies to all the contractors we
use and services we provide through the
website because a resident of mine has a
very strange experience recently where
they'd waited for quite some time to
have the large item collection resumed
when it was they put in to have this
mattress removed and were told that
three days later they would get
confirmation of when that would be
collected after three days they'd
received nothing at all so they got in
touch and then got an email back saying
that an email had been sent to them
telling them when it would be collected
but when but they claimed that they sent
the email three days before the customer
had asked for the mattress to be
collected so obviously that wasn't
correct
so never mind the date was there but
when they tried to feed back it was on a
no reply email
so you know it concerned me on all sorts
of levels because I wondered how many
mattresses were not being collected
because nobody knew they were coming but
and that kind of thing but I just don't
see
but you I just don't see how we can
honestly say that we're capturing both
positive feedback and complaints and
having a clear system if we're not
ensuring that we've got that feedback
and possibility there because people
won't just go somewhere else they'll try
to answer the email another thing was
and I've got one more thing chair coming
to 3.3.2 where we're looking at the
formal consultation on strategy members
public and partners I just wanted to ask
the question of how that strategy
um sorry how that consultation would be
led what the strategy for that was
because I wouldn't like to see it just
online because obviously then we won't
get all the feedback from that that we
need from people that don't use online
services thank you
Ms Green
can you answer that last question uh
certainly chairman so the our normal
approach with any form of strategy is to
ensure that that consultation's on paper
as well as online so we would normally
put pay for copies in libraries GP
surgeries that kind of thing so I can
actually assure members that that will
be as inclusive as possible
Council of stilts
thank you Mr Mayor um I want to agree
with the I'm sorry Mr chairman I'm in
the wrong meeting
whilst I I do agree with everything
that's been said I want to go back some
councilor Fleming said
um I was also on that meeting in
December
um and I believe we actually set up that
working group at that meeting how many
times has that made working group
actually met
why are we not now implementing this
instead of a virtual hub
um members I don't have that information
to hand I believe there has been at
least two meetings and possibly three
with our partners
thank you
um councilor Lagann
um very briefly it's very brief it's a
it's a question since the council
offices were opened the day after which
I really appreciate I know members do
where's the publicity where are we
shouting from the rooftops to say your
council's open I haven't seen any of
that I think I think um councilor
flocker do you really want to speak or
was you just being Mr questions
we should be celebrated there's more
questions before I ask Ms Green to
respond
Council Fluker
I wanted to speak specifically to the
strategy and the words in this report so
I will give way because Council leggings
Miss Green
members it is on our website the ability
to contact us and to make an appointment
and to come see this is on our website
there is a delicate balance but with our
digital first approach in that we want
to sustain our current Channel shift but
equally we do need to make sure that
those customers that do need to come and
see us
um are able to well that's
discriminatory that's discrimination
against people who can't go online the
89 year olds are not the people in the
morning goodness it's Chronicle papers
excluding before I come before I come to
the leader kind of I'll remind
Council fluka
Germany this this thing about
non-accepting checks and not having you
know
people don't have digital access I mean
this screen will remember the time when
my mother refused to pay her council tax
because they didn't accept checks
anymore and she wrote on it I'd rather
go to prison when she got her summons
and uh I'm sure my screen was thinking I
wish your son would go as a proxy but
chairman
um I just wanted to talk to paragraph
3.2 and this business about right first
time Service delivery I mean Kevin
anybody that reads this who's engaged
with the council I mean for example Mr
and Mrs B four months ago I took up a
complaint with the council regarding
some tree work this is an elderly couple
in southminster they put in an
application to have a treat nobody's
come back to them so last night parish
council meeting they throw pelters at me
because of the lack of service and
response Mr n chairman failed to get a
response from the council over a
planning application last September he
was waiting for a response from the
council nothing he's just uh appealed
for predetermination
the non-determination what is going on
when I took that out with the planning
department I said oh sorry
and I've got the emails yeah and the
other thing is German
um a councilor contacted the enforcement
team on four occasions over eight weeks
regarding a case in a Conservation Area
neighboring a list of building
um
I made I've actually said it was me so
Kevin several emails were were exchanged
over that eight week period and towards
the end of that eight weeks it came to
light that the the complaint had never
been recorded
so when I read about the strategy it
concerns me enormously we're saying to
the customers they're being dealt with
immediately and quickly uh through this
strategy but they're not and chairman
why if a member asks a direct question
of an officer by email how many
vacancies there are in the planning
department you don't get a reply I
presume the answer is no because there's
none being advertised on the website
German who is an old saying and it says
keep wearing a pig won't make it grow
fatter and I'm sure you're aware of that
and I think what we need to do uh what
is an old farming expression so
basically basically keep going around
keep going around I mean we
you know we write these reports and I
know they're totally well intentioned
but we do seem to be going around in
certain circles rather than feeding the
pig we just keep weighing it and there
isn't any change and I think all of
these points that these the members have
said this afternoon are well rehearsed
um and it still doesn't seem as though
they've been taken up and you know if
you're going even if you're going to
Tesco's now and there's this I don't
know if you've seen it chairman a
wonderful thing whereby self-service and
this thing bleeps and everything comes
up there is always somebody there to
help you and I don't always think that's
the case downstairs and and chairman of
course the point of order it would be
shame to stand up not wench mention one
uh and and chairman I would just direct
you to uh paragraph two and remind you
chairman
uh that this Council has agreed not to
have reports for noting presented to it
thank you okay
um
no excuse
I was going to point out
um
that this is a report for noting and I'm
getting the clear distinct impression
that members are unhappy with this
report
um but I uh there's no resolution to
make on this
um I'll come to the leader and perhaps
oh sorry Council stilts thank you Miss
uh Mr chairman I did want to come back
um my question going on from what I
asked was who are our partners on the
one Malden Hub and also when we set up
that working group were you not on that
working group Miss Green
Miss Green
um indeed I was
I can get you a list of all the partners
of the one partnership that's absolutely
no problem at all
can I ask Miss green
um uh what would be the effect of
further work on this is there a time
scale on it
Miss green
um whether the the time scale for the
customer strategies is in the report
chairman in terms of a more detailed
timetable and more detailed information
about the community Hub very happy to
bring a further report back on that to
next Council chairman yeah Mr Holmes
thanks chairman and thank you members
for your feedback this afternoon and we
do we we are listening I just wanted to
remind ourselves that within our
corporate plan we do have an objective
um around providing good job services
and officers at the moment are looking
at a number of performance indicators
some of the issues that you've
highlighted this afternoon May well fall
within those indicators so you'll be
able to track the performance and
challenge through the normal as well and
also
um remind us that we've talked about
digital first but meeting the needs of
all customers and that's what you're
effectively saying so yep we absolutely
understand that situation it is in the
corporate plan we will develop those
indicators and you will get that
tracking and performance it's not there
yet but obviously it's coming vegan
thank you chairman um yes absolutely
this report was for an update and
obviously Mr Holmes has just
acknowledged comments members have made
throughout points being raised so I
won't reiterate them all and certainly
uh Miss green thank you very much for
answering all those points uh regarding
um the strategy I'm one of those that
actually and my screen will tell you
this has always said about elderly
persons or those persons that don't have
access
um to um the internet or anything or to
go on the web and I have had assurances
this strategy as the report does
highlight will indicate that it's it's
got to obviously deliver as the
conclusion says to customers or
residents clear approach to delivering
quality services that's what our
customer needs all residence needs are
and also ensure that it is has
availability as it does through uh
through one route but also for those
people that need to access a different
way telephone and face to face I have
been given assurances that will be the
case we need to be inclusive and the
report does highlight that and going
forward the engagement are set out with
residents will be important as well with
members and I'm fully confident that
what will come back is a strategy that
meets the needs that members have
highlighted today
regarding the one muldham partnership I
made a few notes on that quite just
appointed to hear that can people
consider it um not really done anything
because I sit on that as does councilor
siddle and and I actually will refute to
that because quite frankly it is a
developing with a view to bring together
key Partners across this District to
address the Strategic issues around
Health economy and Community safety and
support that affects us all and I'm sure
those members that do sit on it
including Chancellor for lemon will
acknowledge that and actually this past
year I would see has actually seen the
successful development and delivery of
the One World and District partnership
it brings together those key strategic
partners and it is the NHS and we've got
also excellent chairman in Jane Gardner
who is the Deputy police fire and crime
commissioner and the partnership has
played a key role in the development of
the council's UK shared Prosperity fund
program and has been the focus for
partnership working in addressing the
impact of the cost of living crisis on
Modern District residents we obviously
as the council are doing that very much
but we have had great assistance to
partnership and understanding the focus
of across all of our district for our
residents at this time it also I would
like to acknowledge that the one modern
District community service Services
guide has actually recently been
featured by the local government
Association as National best practice
alongside the Innovative storage
container Storage Center for household
essentials which was developed as a
community resource and the community
abide provides key information and
support and health and well-being energy
saving tips and a host of other things
now admittedly the work of the
partnership is developing I and it is
emerging plan includes priorities which
surround health and well-being focusing
on Obesity mental health and addressing
the suicide rate in our district and
those issues I hasten to add are also
embedded on our corporate plan which are
vital to the overall well-being of our
communities and it is through this
partnership working that we will be able
to address the wider determinants of
Health such as housing economic
opportunities and Community safety now
the community Hub as I understand it and
a number of us was there in fact
councilor siddle Council Fleming
councilor stilts and myself at that
meeting where it was discussed and I do
recall it going away the working group
has met I thought there were subgroups
as well and indeed not only should it be
this Council have an awareness of it but
actually that body shall be reporting
back to the one Malden District
partnership that is my understanding as
well it's in very vital that body from
which this was born as is kept up to
speed and has a Viewpoint as well as
this Council and chairman I think I've
learned it there so it was really a
report for noting but I will actually
stand in defense of the one Malden
District partnership it is a good
partnership it is it's a fundamental
partnership going forward for this
Authority and helps us with everything
we need to deliver in terms of
resilience and I will bring benefit
um to this Council to this council's
residence sorry
well I'm just answering with those
criticism of it doing the thing and
regarding the customer strategy I would
highlight and the community Hub or both
or should support individual and
Community resilience thank you chairman
um the leader has summed up but I think
councilor siddle wants to say a few
words
um thank you chairman
um nobody is criticizing
the the one Malden
at the principal you know nobody's
criticizing the work that has taken
place nobody everybody values what we've
put together what we're disappointed in
is where we are at the moment
in terms of the community Hub and the
principle now that it it seems to be
this virtual thing rather than a
physical thing I would rather escalate
to a physical thing sooner rather than
this virtual thing and that's where the
thing so I know that all members are
very supportive of one molden because
it's a fantastic initiative so there is
no criticism of one Malden it's just the
fact that perhaps we're a little bit
disappointed with where we are in terms
of the community thank you Council
um I I believe that the officers have
and um Mr Holmes has alluded to it that
he has noted members concerns so if I
ask you uh to note the report uh and the
comments that have been made noted yeah
um is that is that acceptable agreed
can I have a more assertive
agreed good thank you
um uh now we've got agenda item 13
questions for the leader of the council
in accordance with procedure rule one
three m
House of stilts
thank you Mr chairman I did I did send
my question to the leader beforehand so
that she can have a response to this
um I have been asked by a member of the
public so that is what is brought this
question about
and it's a regarding the sea the annual
season ticket at the prom Park and I
understand that the charges have gone up
but what I don't understand is why we
are only allowing our season tickets
hold us two hours a day
a parking permit for Essex County
Council parks cost 60 pound a year and
allows parking from sunrise to sunset
seven days a week
we are promoting our tourism and some of
our season ticket holders will be people
that actually work in that tourism
industry and we are going to stop them
because they can only use that season
ticket for two hours thank you Mr Mayor
Mr chairman
I've been promoted
um leader
thank you chairman I'll make sure I get
it get it right because it could be
infectious
um can I thank councilor Stills yes she
did sort of give an indication that this
question would be coming forward so in
response to that what I would like to
say is um the policy uh for the car park
permits for prom park has not changed
for 2023 to 2024 say for the annual
percentage increase
there was a change of policy
and charge that was approved by members
for
2022-23 now that would have gone through
that would have been in that budget so
that would have gone through that year
um 2020 uh in fact it went yes to would
have gone through the stratum resources
committee and the finance working group
prior to that details of the background
of the change I'm now going to give you
um so I've just had to say going forward
we have secured funding to undertake a
review of car park charges and
development of a car park charging
strategy during 2023 and that again has
been highlighted to members both at the
finance working group and indeed
strategy and resources and that will
include a review of car parking
concessions now member involvement in
the development of the strategy will be
through the reinstatement of the car
parking task and finish working group in
fact I asked that question when there's
a the item was under consideration
regarding Car parks at the statute
resources can committee now the outcome
of that work will be brought back to
members to consider a mid-year review of
car park charges and to inform the
2024-25 car park Charges going forward
now there are actually still two permits
available for the prom Park a full
permit that allows parking all day and a
two-hour permit such as for dog walkers
now this is where I referred to
2022-23 and that was the budget setting
I became leader in January 19th I think
it was and I had I presented the budget
as was but prior to that I obviously
wasn't the leader and I wasn't the
chairman of strategy and resources
in 2021 the car parking pernic charges
were reviewed in order to ensure
consistency across car Parks this
identified that non-residents using the
prom Park were able to purchase an
annual Car Park permit for substantially
less than the local residents given the
proximity to the High Street this
present did an inconsistency in that
residents who live and work in Malden
were paying significantly higher car
particles than someone that worked in
Malden but lived Outside The District in
2021-22 there were three non-resident
permits issued which represented North
Point North one percent of the total car
part income for the prom
to ensure consistency
the car park permits for prom Park were
brought into line with the permit costs
for other car Parks however a new
two-hour permit was introduced and I'm
now talking about that year where the
considerations were made for the prom to
ensure residents who use the car park
for short stays such as dog walking
could do so without a proportionate cost
the changes were proposed and agreed as
part of actually the 2022-23 fees and
charges policy and fee sitting which
would have started in 2021 and gone
through strategy and resources committee
and then on to council when they'd
agreed the budget during the 2023-24
season charges setting purpose members
did raise the possibility of a resident
scheme as mentioned the remit of the car
parking charging strategy will include a
review of concessions both for Resident
and non-resident charges I hope that's a
full response to help me I'm happy to
give you a copy of that response and
also circulate it to all members if that
helps Council Stan thank you chairman
hopefully my the response to get from
the leader might be a little bit shorter
oh sorry
um mine is um I attended a scrutiny
training meeting this morning
um regarding cabinet systems with Essex
County Council and it picked something
in my little mind chairman and leader is
that if in the near future things change
here and if this Administration stays
the same or if we get a different
Administration do you as the leader or
would you as the leader support a
cabinet system with all its challenges
that it brings and lack of training and
skill Etc would you support it coming to
the modern District Council chair at
leader and if you say yes or no can you
give your reasons only shortly reasons
though
well you know I could give a whole book
on that possibly uh cancel us now if you
want my views on it
um this Council has retained a committee
system and I've been here like Council
boys a fair number of years and in fact
we did try a cabinet hybrid systems a
number of years ago
um I was not in agreement with that but
I obviously went with the council
decision that was applied
then I can tell you at that time because
this all came about I think largely
because the localism ACT 2011 and
everything and then what happened was
um there was a move to try and make oh
I'm sure Council boys will come
um correct me if I'm wrong to go with
the cabinet system and it went to
consultation and that it fell so
therefore I upheld um What the residents
wanted and we retained a cabinet system
ever since I will be threat sorry
committee system well I'm getting caught
up now I can see pros and cons with both
um obviously the cabinet system where I
think it does create more
marginalization for some members because
they become what I would call true back
benches in that terminology and indeed
it then gives one person the leader the
cape uh the chance or power yes to a
point exactly who they want now with the
council like ours where the numbers are
you know
um very very close I suppose they could
be perceived benefit it's where it would
have helped situations because getting
seats on committees and you know making
sure there was a balance but actually
um I think my views I've been a
supporter for a committee system for a
long while and certainly I know the
residents in my world unless anything
has changed in fact it was very vocal in
my ward at the time we did do that
consultation and what I would say is I'm
aware of councils that actually adopted
a cabinet system and have reverted to
committee and likewise I know the other
way around where committee has gone well
I would say having been an Essex County
Council I can see how actually it speeds
up business on occasions and County
Council is a big beast much bigger than
this so actually there's a lot more
going on it has the benefits of an ovian
screw coming over and overview and
scrutiny committee is what I would call
a very true overview and security
Community it can actually summon people
we have a good overview and scrutiny we
have to function in a slightly different
way than you would under a cabinet but
um is that I know then
um I think
I think largely I come down I'm used to
a committee system I have been in the
cabin I could see the benefits but
largely I think
um I'm hoping whatever comes forward
after elections or anything the council
has a right to consider governance
structures I'm aware that some probably
are at the moment I think I have come
down on a committee system because it
involves and actually I tell you a
gentleman who actually
um
so I think there's a side at the back
there German there's a 15-minute rule I
think that the leader of the council is
syllabus and you're taking up the 15
minutes I'm sorry I find that very
offensive to accuse me of filibustering
I'm I'm chairman can we move on I'm
answering I'm answering counselor stamps
no what I want to say is I actually met
a gentleman called count uh Tony
Wedgewood Ben
and I no yes I've never forgotten his
words he asked me what the governance
was at this Council and I said committee
now bear in mind where views may have
come from he said very good don't ever
change it it's the most democratic way
to operator Council thank you thank you
uh your next Council of Luca thank you
that could be very very short and he's
prompted me to ask the leader would the
leaders support the more of a global
publication strategy to allow the
residents of the district to know that
the council officers are open
yes thank you that's a very good
question I can answer it very simply yes
thank you chairman
um first of all Tim and if if the piece
of paper that I've shown today is
correct then uh which came from the
modern constituency conservative
Association then councilor channel is
indeed standing down at the end of this
Administration I think chairman before
you start the clock uh I would just like
to pay tribute to councilor Channel
um she she led the planning and I see
she chaired the planning licensing
committee through a very difficult
period chairman and and also delivered
the local development plan and you
should be remembered for that the local
development plan well chairman there we
go
you delivered it in an envelope
delivered the corporate plan uh four
months early and what I wanted to ask
the leader was apart from increasing
Council taxis uh increasing parking
charges uh and fees and charges
generally and proposing a budget of a
two a two million pound overspend in the
next two years and presiding over what
can only be described as a heartbreaking
and massive rise in homelessness and the
council waiting list
what else have you achieved later in the
last 12 months and why would anybody
vote conservative in May
I think I think the purpose of League
questions to the leader has a caveat
that says not to continue with business
that's previously been that's what it
does
um uh mentioned so I'm gonna have to
disallow that question
yeah okay which I mean I mean really
intuitive and I find that balling
what a load of old I won't read the
final word that's just being texted me
but anyway I think that's extraordinary
German because I think that the the
people of this District need to
understand the political policies of
those that administrate this Council
um
my next question chairman is uh leader
are you satisfied with the income that's
being generated through the project the
corporate project strategy
that has actually been discussed as you
well know at the finance working group
where I'm very well aware of your views
the corporate strategy
um going forward or the commercial
strategy I think you're referring to
um as you know Falls very much many of
those projects within a certain working
group so I'm not going to expand on that
and also um chairman I would say there's
various things coming up later which I
cannot now go into in detail because of
the confidential nature of them so it's
early days I would say but actually I
would say it was refreshed and renewed
as you recall only recently in fact I
referred to it I believe in either the
budget statement or my leader statement
and it is moving forward and we have
certain reports coming forward so
I hope very much we have already had one
come forward before which I can't go
into detail and I was very disappointed
with the result of this Council on that
so chairman it's not a case of of our of
our officers sometimes we have to look
to members that may be delaying things
uh your next question Council of Luca
thank you chairman and thank you for
your generosity look I know that was a
tricky question and clearly it wasn't
answered so I put the leader down it was
answered well I think I just asked were
you satisfied and I'd never got a I
never got this the the the answer to the
question so I'll accept the leaders
neither satisfied nor unsatisfied
um chairman I proposed a motion to this
leader I proposed a motion to this
Council
um regarding the local development plan
and emerging policies and I remember and
I've listened to the tape and I can
remember that senior members of this
Council
said that the Healer document the Healer
document was not an emerging policy
so can you explain to me why leader
and bear in mind those comments from
senior members of the council and from
officers
why Mr kenman Lane the planning
inspector
actually
concluded that they were
I I don't quite understand that leader
um well I I think I know what I I think
I think I know what council of Luca is
referring to and the issue he wants me
to expand on
however what I'm going to say is I'm
regarding that matter which you've now
highlighted in this chamber
this is a complex and nuanced issue in
which the comments
on costs are the area in which the
inspector focuses comments on the Healer
rather than the appeal decision itself
and I can tell you Council hooker there
was a response given to you did have an
email officers are still reviewing
detail and respond in due course and I'm
making no further comment today
regarding that but you have had the same
emails that I have thank you
any other questions thanks chairman so
um going back to my previous comment
would you believe would you agree with
me that that's just a case of weighing
the pig because chairman this leader
this is an incredibly important thing I
need an answer for this Council that
leader through you over what's going on
last night a planning application leader
came to southminster council for 249
houses yeah with a note from the
applicant saying the site had been
approved
by the policy team of this Council bear
in mind there's been no input from
Members into the decision making over
the call for sites do you believe that's
correct
leader
chairman I hope I thought I'd answered
the points raised and what I would say
I'm not sure what councilor fluke is
talking about that went to southminster
Parish Council last night or what he was
asked there what I will say is Chairman
at this time I'm going because of the
association with something else I'm not
prepared to make any comment and what I
would say we were told and I do recall
that during the meetings the healer is
evidence and not policy 15 minutes are
up so
um not commenting any further chairman
15 minutes uh our app members on on
questions to the leader I think we've
slightly done above
um so we now come to uh agenda item 14
business by reason of special
circumstances considered by the chairman
to be urgent I have no such business I
cannot move the 15 the exclusion of the
public and press because we have to
start again at seven o'clock
uh with the information that uh Council
Fluker required regards to the minutes
points of order uh what's your point of
order
um chairman this is to do with the
summons issued in advance for Council
meetings and the chairman the summons
that's been issued has to take
precedence over any other correspondence
and chairman look I know your team I've
already you have chamber but I think
because I know that people now uh you
know obviously we're going to go into
private and confidential but again
you'll you'll bring this all back this
evening this seems to be a welfare it's
not my my wish a chairman is your gender
and chairman I haven't actually finished
I arranged uh the agenda as best I was
able with the information I had at that
time now officers are not available to
continue uh with the evening meeting
they've been arranged to be on call uh
from seven o'clock but chairman we've
got three directors here surely they can
they can deal with this if they can't
then they're not brief themselves I find
this and you can't go against the
summons Jim uh
councilor fluka I would love to continue
the meeting uh now uh but
um I there are members that are expected
to turn up this evening uh yes yes there
is there are uh and um I'll
continue to what I've said so that there
is not a point of order
um
uh I I cannot move the exclusion of the
public and press because we have to come
back for the information that councilor
fluca requires
uh so I'm adjourning until seven
[Music]
thanks